he is quitting but is clearly very
unhappy around the circumstances which
he feels he's been forced to go Mr Rob
made it very clear that if any of the
complaints were upheld he would resign
two complaints have been upheld and
therefore he's felt compelled to stand
down but in the letter he makes it very
clear that he believes the thresholds
are too low by which these claims have
been
upheld uh he says that it's such a
dangerous precedent he says he's
genuinely sorry for any unintended
stress or offense that officials felt
but he also goes on to say this as I
said the satin for bullying is so low
this inquiry is set a dangerous
president it will encourage spurious
complaints against ministers and have a
chilling effect on those driving change
on behalf of your government and
ultimately the British people he goes on
to say as Rob was pointing out that he
still supports the government and still
supports Mr sunak so where does it leave
the Prime Minister well in a way Anna
for for Mr Rob to resign rather than ask
the prime minister to for compel the
prime minister to have to sack him it
makes it easier for Richie soon at
because Mr Rob has resigned of his own
accord he hasn't forced the hand of his
boss but where does it leave Rishi sunak
well it leaves him without his closest
political Ally a loyal Lieutenant he
loses his Deputy Prime Minister he's
going to have to re-configure uh his
cabinet now and and in terms of some of
the remarks that Mr Rob made in his
resignation letter there has been a
sense from some ministers that Mr Rob
was being forced out by the civil
service now of course civil servants
would contest that but some ministers
and former cabinet ministers might see
this as a sort of win of Whitehall
against the government and that it sets
as Rob has said a Preston in which more
claims can be made against ministers